nous passons maintenant à notre
chronique dès aujourd'hui pendant cinq
jours la france fait la nature plus de
mise animations gratuites sont proposées
au public en ile-de-france des lieux
habituellement fermés ouvrent leurs
portes pour sensibiliser les curieux à
la protection et au respect de la nature
pour en parler et découvrir le programme
de cette édition ce soir en plateau avec
nom mélanie poté bonsoir à mélanie ce
nom sans floral alors la fête de la
nature elle fête cette année ses 10 ans
elle est à l'initiative du comité
français de l'union internationale pour
la conservation de la nature et terre
sauvage un magazine spécialisé
elle est organisée par l'association
fête de la nature qui rassemble des
acteurs nationaux comme l'office
national des forêts ou le muséum
national d'histoire naturelle mais aussi
des acteurs régionaux comme natureparif
l'agencé régionale pour la nature et la
biodiversité en ile de france bruno myle
yens son président nous en explique que
le but
les acteurs qui opère auprès de la
batture que ce soit vigie nature que ce
soit ne furent pas ce soit mais des
maires qui sont qui sont qui sont
sensibilisés à cela que ce soit nos
petits enfants vous en citer d'autres
que ce soit la fève et ont participé à
cette fête de la nature
les gens qui viendront découvrir des
choses dont on n'imaginait même pas 1
l'existence et de l'importance tous ces
petits trucs pour essayer de comprendre
que la batture ce qu'elles étaient avant
ce qu'elle est devenue pourquoi il faut
qu'on ment réintroduisent la fête de la
nature est importante pour soi ce sont
ces petits attendu par le public l'an
dernier 200 mille personnes avaient
participé à cette semaine sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines nature donne aussi rendez vous
au public est fait et les animations ont
même commencé déjà depuis ce matin avec
l'opie office pour les insectes et leur
environnement qui est basé à guyancourt
les plus jeunes ont été un des invités à
découvrir les petites bêtes dans leur
milieu de vie mais aussi ont été un
court instant de petits entomologiste
mais l'office propose d'autres
animations mathieu de flores chargé de
mission vous donne un rendez-vous lopy
s'occupe d'un milieu
eux qui appartient à louer nef donc
l'office national des forêts on appelle
ce mieux on espaces l'espace nature du
val d'or qui est au niveau des étangs de
la minière c'est un espace qui a accès
exceptionnel parce qu'en fait il est
entièrement fermé au public qu'en temps
normal à part pour des animations mais
donc on a laissé on l'a clôturée et on a
laisser la nature reprendre un peu ses
droits
on va vous faire découvrir les petites
bêtes qui habite dans ce milieu là qui
est à deux pas de versailles et on a
vraiment eu l'impression d'être perdu
dans la nature alors qu'on est vraiment
on a vraiment à 5 minutes de versailles
en voiture et pour les plus grands qui
voudraient eux aussi découvrir le métier
d'entomologiste lopy donne rendez-vous à
châteaufort le samedi 21 mai de 15
heures à 17 heures et si vous n'avez
jamais eu l'occasion d'entrer au sein de
la réserve naturelle de saint quentin en
yvelines
cette dernière ouvre ses portes pour une
visite guidée c'est toujours le 21 mai
mais lassé de 14h à 16h30 attention la
réservation est obligatoire pour tous et
rendez vous pour le 22 mai le dernier
jour de la fête de la nature c'est aussi
la journée internationale de la
biodiversité
alors pour découvrir ou redécouvrir les
lieux yvelinois et s'informer sur la
biodiversité et ses acteurs le programme
est à retrouver sur le site internet de
la fête de la nature